i think hispanic voters across the
country care about the things that
everybody cares about they want
prosperity for themselves and for their
children
they want
you know low taxes they want to be safe
in their communities and i think it's
it's apparent that uh the republican
party is addressing those issues not
only at the city level but certainly at
the national level and it's resonating
that was the mayor of miami francis
suarez on this program last month on
hispanic voters flocking toward the gop
he was proven right on tuesday when
republican maida flores won the special
election in texas 34th district which
has been democrat for more than 100
years flores also made history as the
first congresswoman elected to be born
in mexico her victory not only signals
the diversification of the gop but also
the potential of a red wave come
november the congresswoman elect is
expected to be sworn in this upcoming
week early in the week but first maida
flores is joining me right now maida
congratulations to you thanks for being
here
thank you so much thank you for having
me and first happy father's day to all
the amazing fathers out there and of
course a special happy father's day to
my father and my amazing husband as well
yes absolutely and and mine as well so
you flipped a seat in
an 84 hispanic district that has been uh
democrat ron for a hundred years what
changed
well to be honest with you south texas
has always been conservative we're all
about faith and family and hard work
that's exactly who we are but the
democrat party took us for granted they
feel entitled to our vote making the
same promises over and over and really
not making nothing happen
and i honestly had enough i was really
fed up with the compadrismo here in
south texas and that's the reason why i
decided to run and of course the
republican party is investing now in
south texas and that helps us
significantly in getting the funding out
there to the entire district to be able
to
to tell them that the republican party
is fighting for their values that maida
flores is fighting for their values
values that are worth fighting for
mata uh president biden won your
district by 13 points in 2020
your husband is a border agent we talk
about the wide open border all the time
is this uh the the main issue for the
hispanic voter what can you tell us
about the hispanic voter and
what you're expecting in terms of votes
come november
well the main issue is inflation it's
the cost of living everyone is
extremely pissed off angry at the buying
administration because of the increase
of gasoline of groceries
of medication that is hurting them
tremendously not only here in south
texas but in the entire country and of
course the border crisis is something
that we see here right behind our
backyards it's not something that we
need to be told by the news it's
something that we're seeing here every
single day and me that i came here when
i was six years old i was blessed to
come here legally but i don't want my
experience to be a rare experience i
want more children like myself to be
able to come here to united states
legally as well and dubai
administration's policies are only
hurting immigrants hurting the american
people and because of him we hadn't we
have an increase of child trafficking in
this country and this is all on the
biden administration and vicente
gonzalez was part of the problem as well
here in south texas
yeah i saw it myself when i was on the
ground at the border uh ref referring to
what you're talking about in terms of
the child trafficking it is just a
devastating story i want to talk about
immigration legal immigration let's take
a short break but you're married to a
border patrol agent as i mentioned he's
on the front lines of this crisis
exploding in your backyard a record 239
000 migrants apprehended last month uh
that's not including the got aways one
talk solutions and legal immigration
when we come right back stay with us
[Music]
welcome back and i'm back with texas
congresswoman elect maida flores and
maida let me get your take on what the
solutions could be
we have seen another record month in
terms of
apprehensions at the southern border you
mentioned the child trafficking what do
you want to see with regard to legal
immigration
well i want to improve the process you
know i do believe that it's outdated so
we need a process where it's you know
safer and faster for the good people
that want to come here to united states
and work hard for the american dream i
do believe that we need to focus on
legal immigration and not illegal
immigration that is only funding
criminal organizations and of course
also increasing uh human smuggling and
human trafficking and also child
trafficking and children are innocent no
matter where they're from i think that
they need to be our priority in keeping
them safe and the bad administration is
not doing that
yeah i mean at this point might i'm told
that the drug cartels are taking home
200 million dollars a week i mean it's
just extraordinary how much money these
uh criminal cartels are making and they
are running the border of america uh
alejandro mayorkas uh says the borders
closed if you can believe that jim
jordan was on this program a couple of
weeks ago he says he should be impeached
and what do you think about kamala
harris the vice president is supposed to
be the borders are
the vice president is useless and i do
agree that he should be impeached he is
only looking after himself
and the biden administration he's not
looking after the border patrol agents
are out there every single day risking
their lives and constantly getting
criticized by this administration
for enforcing the laws that they put in
place and we need to go we need to start
enforcing the laws that we already have
and put back the policies that the
previous administration had that were
working and that's the reality under
trump we did not have this border crisis
that's a fact we did not have this
inflation that is a fact and we need to
go back to that
mata real quick before you go you're
going to get sworn in early next week
and then you've got to do this again in
november how do you feel about competing
with the democrat uh in the midterms
well honestly uh it makes no difference
i'm very confident in the work that
we're doing here in south texas i'm very
proud of my amazing team and we're going
to win that re-election through hard
work and dedication okay
maida thank you maya flores joining us